Speaker 1: Despite the fact that more than half
of Republicans are ready to say, baby to Donald
Trump, he's still the most popular Republican.
And the dynamics of a crowded primary in 2024
would almost certainly benefit him in the same way
that he benefited from a crowded field in 2016,
but to a significantly greater
degree. And we're going to explain why
a crowded GOP field could help Trump in 24,
writes Jill Colvin from the Associated Press.
As Donald Trump considers another White House
run, polls show he's the most popular figure
in the Republican Party. But it wasn't always that
way. Competing at one point against a dozen rivals
in 2016, Trump won only about a third of the
vote in key early states. He even lost in Iowa.
But he prevailed because those in the party
who opposed his brand of divisive politics
never coalesced along a single rival. And
the same thing could repeat itself as Trump
considers a new bid for the presidency as soon
as this summer. With a growing list of candidates
gearing up to run. Even a Trump diminished by two
impeachments and mounting legal vulnerabilities
could hold a commanding position in a fractured
multi-candidate primary. And the article goes
on to say, interestingly, that anxiety is
mounting as there is a growing list of rivals,
potential rivals taking increasingly brazen steps.
This includes Mike Pence, Mike Pompeo, Ted Cruz,
Tom Cotton, Rick Scott, Tim Scott, Liz Cheney and
Larry Hogan are raising profiles. And, of course,
Ron DeSantis increasingly seen as Trump's heir
apparent. So the scenario with the crowded field
is almost certainly good for Trump if the
Republican Party. And I'm not giving them
advice. It's an observation. If the Republican
Party said we want to put party over person
and defeat Trump at all costs so we can have
someone, quote, more normal as our nominee,
they should really coalesce around someone
early. I don't know that the dynamics of the
Republican Party allow that. I don't know that
the Republican Party is willing or interested in
sort of anointing someone to replace Trump. And
so what you could end up with if DeSantis runs,
if whoever if any of these people run is okay,
Nikki Haley runs and holds 3% for a while
and ultimately drops out. That's probably worse
for DeSantis and better for Trump. Two of that
might go to Trump, and one of her three points
goes to DeSantis. Trump consolidated support a
little bit. Then Ted Cruz pulls 4% for a while.
It ultimately becomes clear Ted Cruz isn't going
to be the nominee. Again, Trump wins by attrition
in a similar way to what happened in the 2016
primary. And there's sort of a couple different
layers of this. One is when you zoom out,
Donald Trump incited an insurrection to try to
overturn the actual winner of the 2020 election.
He attempted to defraud the electoral vote
count with all of these different techniques,
asking for 11,000 votes in Georgia, fake electors,
all this different stuff. And he still would
apparently easily win a primary if it were
held today. That says as much or more about
the Republican primary voter than it does
about Trump. We know plenty about Trump,
but it says a lot about the primary voter that
after all, that they'd still be willing to vote
for him. A plurality would over any other
candidate. But the other aspect of this is
how committed is the Republican Party to
actually removing Trump? Because, listen,
if at this point, 51% of their voters are
already interested in someone other than Trump,
not the same someone, but someone other than
Trump, the best thing that they could do
is try to consolidate support around someone
early. If they decided, based on the polling,
that DeSantis is their best shot, they should be
working towards steering away other people from
running and trying to build up. Ron DeSantis At
least for now, publicly, they're not doing that.
Although tomorrow on the show I am going to tell
you about the fundraising moves of Ron DeSantis
apparently trying to court some of the large
Republican mega-donors. My guess would be if
the large mega-donors say to Sanders, we will
support you, we would rather you than Trump.
It seems that that could get his campaign off to
a fast start. If, on the other hand, they say,
if it's Trump, we've got to support Trump
because that's still where most of our voters are
or a plurality of our voters. That may
dissuade DeSantis from even running.
But this is very precarious for the Republican
Party because so many Republicans now,
particularly because there was no real primary in
the Republican side in 2020 who have been saying,
I might want to run. It would be interesting to
run. I would like to run. This is the open primary
and it's hard to dissuade people from running
in an open primary where there is no incumbent.
At the same time, it's bad for them and it's
good for Trump. So I don't know ultimately
what they will do it or how they will manage
it, but we will, of course, be watching it.
And right now, DeSantis is the only guy who
maybe has a shot. We'll have more on this on
The David Pakman Show Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman show also. Oh, by the way,
if you want to hear. A voicemail so vile and so
unhinged that I can't even play it on the podcast.
Check out my personal Instagram David
Pakman. I uploaded it this morning
and it is. It's cuckoo for Cocoa
Puffs. Let's put it that way.